- Whoo-hoo!
I don't know what to say this is.
(jingle bells)
- You know, I love candy canes, frankly.
- I eat a candy cane every day.
- The candy canes I like the
best are the big thick ones.
- Oftentimes I'll take a candy cane and
pop a little bite in and
keep my breath fresh.
- All right, bring on your darndest.
- They always make these
things so hard to open.
(smacking lips)
- It's not as minty as I'm accustom to.
- (smacks lips) Got a coffee flavor to it.
- It's not horrible.
- Burnt popcorn with butter.
- Bacon? Oh my goodness.
I guess I have to try it
again with bacon knowledge.
- It tasted more like coffee.
- (laughing) Santa does
not particularly care for
bacon in his candy.
- Ooh, Santa.
(crunching)
- Mmmm.
- More crunch, on it.
Ooh. Ooh my goodness.
- Well it's not ta ... Oh my goodness.
- It's got a hot spicy to it.
- Kind of burnt this side, now
I've got to burn this side.
Keeps it even (laughs).
- Pizza.
Barbecue sauce?
Hot sauce?
Wasabi?
- Sriracha sauce.
- It wakes you up a little bit.
- I'll probably eat this little piece but,
it just wasn't what I was expecting.
- It does not have the
Santa je ne sais quoi.
- It's not terrible.
(sniffs)
(smacks lips)
- I'm drawing a complete blank.
There's nothing here.
- It's not minty.
- I had a mint flavor.
- It's a regular candy cane.
- I want to say is it lettuce or celery?
- Is it pickle?
- Didn't taste the brine,
didn't taste the pickle.
- Now I'm starting to
get the pickle flavor.
- Ew.
- They're stretching
that one a bit. (laughs)
- Alright, come on. Open up you.
- I don't know that I want
to know what this one is.
- Wooo!
What the heck is that?
- That one's different.
- It has quite a kick to it.
- Glad the stripes aren't brown.
- That green stuff I get
at the Japanese restaurant.
- Is that wasabi?
- Blech.
- No thank you.
- Yes. Santa likes.
- The one with that Vietnamese hot spice,
I kind of like it. (laughs)
- The bacon one tasted really good.
- The wasabi, not so much.
- The wasabi, yes.
(jingle bells)